So,
good morning. I'm Alan D'Andrea from the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute,
and this is a session on DNA damage response and synthetic
lethality in cancer.
I'm going to be giving the first talk,
and I'll introduce synthetic lethality briefly in my talk before I get
into our new data. I'm going to present a new story,
actually.
Then our second speaker is Sharon Kantor from University of
Massachusetts, and she's a DNA repair expert and does
work on single-strand DNA gaps. You'll hear about that in her talk, which are
useful biomarkers for DDR drug development, among
other things.
And then, third speaker is Pamela Munster from UC San
Francisco. A little bit more of a clinical talk, but also working on drug
combinations in homologous recombination deficient tumors.
And maybe she'll have something to say about interaction of DDR drugs like PARP
inhibitors with cytotoxic therapies.
So,
moving forward.
I assume that my slides will be set up by someone.
Ah, perfect. Okay, so this is a new story, so
bear with me.
I always like to say sometimes I see these slides for the first time.
That's not true. But synthetic lethality opportunities for tumors
with MMEJ deficiency, that's microhomology-mediated
end joining deficiency.
Okay. So, as everyone knows, there are at least six
major DNA repair pathways in human cells.
These have various names: base excision repair, nucleotide excision repair,
mismatch repair, homologous recombination.
Actually, the Fanconi pathway, which my lab works on very closely, is part of
homologous recombination, NHEJ and TLS.
Now,
normal human cells have these six DNA repair pathways
to varying degrees depending on the cell type.
But cancer cells are often missing one of these DNA repair pathways.
And this is interesting. This gives an advantage to the cancer, if you
will, because of this DNA repair deficiency, the cancer can now break and reform
chromosomes, generate mutations, knock out p53, and do all the
things that cancers like to do. But it's a vulnerability to this cancer
as well, because by knocking out that DNA repair pathway,
these cancer cells are sensitive to radiation and chemotherapy often.
So for instance,
an example of this is some bladder cancers are deficient in nucleotide
excision repair, and those tumors respond better to cisplatin.
That's one example.
Okay. But this is about synthetic lethality, this session.
Some cancers, when they knock out one pathway,
they become hyper-dependent on another pathway, this big arrow here, and that's
an opportunity for us as targeted therapy scientists and doctors.
If you could develop a drug against this hyperactive therapy like a PARP
inhibitor in a BRCA deficient cell, you can have a way of
monotherapy for developing the drug.
Okay, so this is a principle of synthetic lethality, as I like to
say. All right, so these are the two pathways which I'm going to focus on,
homologous recombination on the left and
microhomology-mediated end joining on the right.
These are two very important pathways which regulate or repair a
double-strand break at the top of the slide.
So homologous recombination is an error-free pathway. Okay?
It uses BRCA1 and BRCA2 and PALB2 and
RAD51C proteins that you all know about
and performs error-free repair during S-phase.
MMEJ is very different. It's a very efficient DNA repair pathway, but
it's maybe utilized less.
It's the same principle that double-strand break is resected a little bit and
then a very important polymerase called Pol Q or Pol
theta, which is one of the 15 human DNA polymerases, plays a major
role here in MMEJ.
And other enzymes like PARP and FEN1, APEX 2 play a role in this
pathway as well. This is an error-prone pathway.
When this pathway is used, there are indels, insertions and
deletions, and point mutations, mutations that you often see in signature three
in a BRCA deficient tumor occurs in mitosis.
Now, we all know this, right?
When a tumor has a deficiency in homologous recombination, BRCA1 or
BRCA2 is mutated, say breast, ovarian, prostate, pancreatic
cancers with BRCA mutations.
Those tumors deficient in HR now upregulate.
They upregulate MMEJ, so there's an increase in expression of Pol
Q. It's one of the reasons that Pol Q inhibitors are under investigation right
now in collaboration with PARP inhibitors.
And now with this upregulation of MMEJ, there's an increase in point
mutagenesis, as I said. So the question for today is the
opposite. Could we find a tumor or tumors which are deficient
in MMEJ at baseline, a defect in Pol theta?
And we would expect that those tumors, because of a defect in Pol theta
and MMEJ, that they would have a hyperactive homologous
recombination pathway and might be sensitive to drugs which
inhibit homologous recombination. Interesting hypothesis.
Okay, so the answer is yes, we found such a tumor, and that tumor is a
Ewing sarcoma. But now we're finding more tumors that have defects in
MMEJ. But Ewing sarcoma is going to be the example.
So how did we find this? So we went to this very important paper from Nature back
in 2013 that looked at mutations in human
tumors across the spectrum. And of course, you find at the far right,
melanomas have lots of point mutations, lots of neoantigens, maybe one of the
reasons immunotherapy is so effective there.
Other tumors kind of in the middle of this graph, like ovarian and
prostate, pancreatic cancer, they have some
increased mutagenesis. But at the far left here, these are interesting
tumors. Rhabdoid tumors and Ewing tumors and
thyroid tumors. These tumors have very low-...
point mutation frequency and very low,
so if you do a mutational signature on these tumors, you find very few mutations,
and you find a low level of insertions and deletions.
So they said to us, "Maybe these tumors have a defect in MMEJ." That was the
hypothesis. Okay, so Ewing sarcoma.
It's a rare cancer. It's the second most common cancer in bone in children.
Results from a chromosome 1122 translocation.
Metastatic disease is quite difficult to treat, a 30%
five-year survival.
These tumors are quite sensitive to DNA-damaging agents, so radiation and
chemotherapy.
High doses, actually. It's a very difficult clinical course for these
young people with Ewing sarcoma.
The tumor is driven by this EWS-FLI1 fusion
protein, shown on the right here. This fusion protein
has EWSR1 at the amino terminus. That's a splicing factor.
Okay? And FLI1 at the carboxy terminus, that's a
transcriptional activator. And there have been some really elegant studies
done with the EWS-FLI1 showing it has
increased transcriptional activity,
and maybe that's driving the cancer development.
But fewer studies have been done on the splicing element, and what I'm going to
show you is that this fusion protein, EWS-FLI1, inhibits
splicing of the Pol theta Polq messenger
RNA.
Okay, so by DepMap analysis, indeed, if you knock out
Polq or if you knock out EWSR1, you can
kill BRCA2-deficient, HR-deficient tumor cells.
So DepMap really showed that, yeah, EWSR1 looks like it's
required for MMEJ, just like Polq is
required. And EWS completion results in loss of
the Polq protein.
Okay? And then you could actually look at this more closely, and you could knock
down EWSR1, the splicing factor. That
disrupts, that lowers DNA repair by
microhomology-mediated end joining.
But you could replace this with Pol theta, put Polq
back in, and now you restore MMEJ. So clearly, it was showing
that this fusion, this EWSR1 splicing factor, was
somehow strongly regulating the expression of Polq.
So how does it do this?
So it does it through splicing. So it turns out, if you knock out
EWSR1,
shown here on the left, in a RPE cell, or retinal
pigment cell, a normal cell if you will, you
get an increase in splicing defects.
So if you knock out EWSR1, you get exon 25
skipping, very important exon in the Polq messenger RNA,
and now the protein is not expressed.
So
exon 25 skipping, caused by a loss of
EWSR1 or by the expression of the fusion
oncoprotein, results in a disruption of splicing and
now skipping of exon 25 of Polq messenger RNA.
We then confirmed this with tumor samples.
So in collaboration with Riaz Gilani and Eli Van Allen,
and some samples collected, actually through a collaboration with
St. Jude as well,
36 Ewing sarcomas were evaluated.
And actually, exon 25 skipping was a common event in those tumors, and
Polq expression was low, suggesting that this was not just an
artifact of cell line study, that in fact, this decrease in
Polq was, in fact, a
reality in these tumors.
Okay, so we wanted to study this more closely then.
How does this splicing factor, EWSR1,
regulate Polq expression? So here's the EWSR1
protein at the top schematically. This is an interesting protein.
It's an RNA-binding protein, like a splicing factor, but it has this
N-terminal region, which is a prion-like domain. Okay?
Now, if you look on the right, if you knock out EWSR1, you get
no Polq expression, lane two. Put the
wild-type EWSR1 splicing factor back in, you restore Polq
expression. But put in the mutant, and you fail to restore.
So there's something about wild-type EWSR1, this full-length protein,
with its prion-like domain, has the ability to properly
splice the messenger RNA for Polq, this
important DNA repair enzyme. So how does this work?
So I'm going to give you the answer first, okay?
Because it's a short talk, but I wanted to sort of get the answer out there and
then show you a little bit about how we came up with this conclusion.
So it turns out that EWSR1, this splicing
factor,
when you immunoprecipitate this protein, it co-precipitates
with two other splicing factors, FKBP1 and
KHSRP, and these splicing factors come together as a
complex, all bound together by these prion-like domains.
And this complex now binds directly to a sequence in
exon 25 of the Polq messenger RNA, and it
stabilizes this exon. So if you knock out this
complex, knocking out EWSR1, or if you
express the fusion protein like the tumor does,
now this exon is not stabilized anymore.
Exon 25 is skipped, and now the cells do not express the Polq
protein, and the cells have a MMEJ DNA repair
deficiency. So that's the answer, and let me tell you how we sort of got to
that.
It turns out that these three proteins, EWSR1 and these two other splicing
factors, form a condensate, and this condensate has the ability now
to act as a splicing condensate and to
stabilize the exon 25 of the
Polq messenger RNA.
And you can see here that if you knock out this splicing
complex, EWSR1 with these two binding factors, now
you cannot form the condensate. You cannot stabilize exon
25.And as a result, the exon is skipped
and POLQ protein drops, and there's no MMEJ.
And the early data really suggests that this is a regulated phenomenon, that in a
cell, depending on DNA damage state, you could either
stabilize this exon or destabilize this
exon and regulate the level of POLQ expression.
Okay, so how does this really work?
How does this condensate stabilize exon 25?
What we did here is we
narrowed it down, we being two very talented postdocs in the lab,
Shuhei Asada and Guangli Xu. What they did is they
found a sequence, a six-base sequence
in the exon of this POLQ messenger RNA, and
this base pair sequence is the binding site for
EWSR1 and this splicing complex. And if you
mutate this
site in messenger RNA, remember, this is an exon, this is a
coding region. You could actually mutate this site but preserve
the amino acid sequence.
That mutation, though, in that site disrupts the binding of the
EWSR1 complex, and you get an exon-skipping event.
And they did this in a very interesting way.
This is a method which has been described where you take a
guide RNA, which is directed against this sequence
in exon 25.
And with that guide RNA, now you
introduce a Cas13, which is a modified
Cas9, which is catalytically inactive.
And that Cas13 now binds to the siRNA at
this site in the exon. And when it does that, it
can block the interaction of the fusion protein and it can block the
interaction of the splicing complex and cause exon skipping.
Even more interesting, you can bring in this Cas13, which is
coupled to a biotin ligase, and now you can
biotinylate the proteins in this complex.
And we were very happy to see, indeed, that when you do this, that
now we can detect this protein complex,
EWSR1 and these two other splicing factors, directly at this
site in exon 25 of the POLQ
messenger RNA.
Now, the question now, of course, becomes, what's the fusion protein doing?
Everything I've told you up till now is this
EWSR1 splicing factor is required for the
proper splicing of POLQ, POL theta.
This is a very important DNA repair protein, and if you don't have
EWSR1 working properly, you're not going to get
this messenger RNA properly spliced, and you're not going to get the
POLQ protein, and you're going to have a DNA repair defect.
What is the fusion protein doing? It turns out the EWS-FLI1
fusion does a lot of things. It's adding a lot to the phenotype
of a Ewing sarcoma cell. It's transcriptionally upregulating various gene
products. But it's also binding to
EWSR1 and inactivating the
EWSR1, and it's inactivating the splicing mechanism,
and even the expression of this fusion protein in
lane three here is disrupting the
recruitment of this EWSR1 splicing
complex to this splicing enhancer
region on exon 25. So this is
complicated, and years ago, I swore that I'd never work on splicing.
We
don't work on splicing, we work on DNA repair, but this is a mechanism which is
clearly regulating DNA repair at a deep level.
And I think that understanding it is going to give us some insight in how
splicing mechanisms can upregulate or downregulate
DNA repair pathways.
Okay, so the conclusion up till this point then of my talk is
this splicing factor, EWSR1,
is a critical splicing factor which regulates the proper
splicing of the POLQ, POL theta messenger RNA.
This EWSR1 interacts with other splicing factors, as I showed you.
They come down together and co-precipitate in mass spec.
You can find these three factors together.
Knockout of any of these splicing factors causes skipping of exon
25 and loss of POLQ expression and an MMEJ
defect.
This complex, EWSR1 splicing complex, binds to
this very specific six-base nucleotide
sequence in the messenger RNA
in the exon 25 of POLQ, and it stabilizes that
exon. So if you knock out EWSR1 or if
you express this fusion protein, you
inactivate the complex, and now you get an MMEJ deficiency.
And Ewing sarcoma cells have exon 25
skipping of this POLQ messenger RNA, decreased POLQ
expression, and this profound DNA repair defect.
So what? Okay, that's interesting science, but so what?
Is there an actionable element to this story?
Is there an opportunity for synthetic lethality?
And to treat Ewing sarcoma, again, which is a disease that
requires very
high levels of alkylating agents and etoposide,
is there a way to add a targeted
therapy to the treatment of this disease?
We don't know yet, but we have an opportunity here.
By the principles of synthetic lethality, we would like to
knock out homologous recombination, but there's no good drugs yet for knocking out
homologous recombination.
You can't knock out RAD51. That's too essential.
But there are inhibitors of CDK12.
CDK12 is a transcriptional CDK which
regulates the expression of BRCA2.
So if you can inhibit CDK12, you'll actually indirectly knock
out homologous recombination. And in fact, Nathaniel Gray, a few years
ago, when he was at Dana-Farber,
generated a beautiful inhibitor of CDK12 and
published this very elegant work with Tim Stegmeyer that showed
that EWS-FLI1In Ewing sarcoma
cells confers tumor synthetic lethality with the CDK12 inhibition.
I think we understand the mechanism of this now.
The CDK12 inhibitor is killing homologous recombination,
which then by synthetic lethality is killing the Ewing tumor
cells, which have an MMEJ deficiency.
And
they've shown, and we've now confirmed, that Ewing sarcoma cell
lines
which have this defect in MMEJ, decreased Pol theta
expression, are very profoundly sensitive to this HR inhibitor.
And actually, if you knock out EWS FLI1, you can actually make the
cells resistant by restoring,
MMEJ activity, and now the cells are resistant to
the HR inhibitor. So,
final summary slide and final slide then is this protein,
EWSR1.
The splicing factor is a critical factor for Pol
q messenger RNA expression and proper splicing.
Now, I'm convinced, I'm sure, that this complex probably
regulates the splicing of a lot of other messenger RNAs, not just the Pol q
messenger RNA. But because the Pol q messenger RNA and the
encoded protein is so important to DNA repair, we think
that this has important relevance to a synthetic
lethal opportunity. Ewing sarcoma cells, this fusion protein
that's made
can bind and inactivate the normal splicing function of
EWSR1.
The sarcoma cells have deficiency in EWSR1
activity and resulting in exon 25 skipping, as I said.
Ewing sarcoma is the first human tumor now that we have which is deficient in
MMEJ, deficient in microhomology-mediated end joining.
I think there's others. We think rhabdoid tumor is going to fall into that
category. We think other sarcomas are going to fall into that category.
Meaning that HR inhibitors, homologous recombination inhibitors, might have a role
in those tumors that have MMEJ deficiency.
We have a biomarker for MMEJ deficiency, the splicing of this
exon 25. And I think the final conclusion of my talk is
synthetic lethality works in both ways.
Tumors that are deficient in BRCA, deficient in HR, right, they're
sensitive to a PARP inhibitor and a Pol theta inhibitor, but if a tumor is
deficient in Pol theta, it's going to be sensitive to an HR inhibitor.
So I think synthetic lethality,
we have the opportunity to work this in two different ways.
These are the people that did work, two very talented postdocs, and these are
members of my laboratory. And just to call out my long-term collaborator,
Jeff Shapiro. We co-direct a DNA repair center at Dana-Farber.
Thank you very much.
I don't know if there's time for... I don't think there is.
Let me see what I have here.
Yeah, I guess I do have a couple minutes to take questions.
There are microphones if anyone
is
here to ask. Yeah.
Nice talk.
You mentioned that when MMEJ becomes
inactive, the HR proficiency goes up.
So can one expect the new antigens to
go
lower? Because normally, MMEJ is supposed to be-
No
... making the tumor hot-
Yeah
... versus cold.
Yeah, no, I think that's quite possible.
Yeah.
So we expect that these tumors to actually have higher
levels of homologous recombination. Right?
Yeah.
One of the reasons they have so few mutations.
But also one of the reasons they may have low levels of neoantigens.
So maybe not a good candidate for immune therapy
in that regard. No, that's good.
Thank you.
Thank you for that. Yeah.
Yeah.
Great talk. I was just interested in other splicing factor.
By any luck, did you check SC35,
SRF, S1, or SUN?
Yeah.
The S34F mutation in
U2AF1, is that what you're asking about? No.
Yeah.
U2AF are other splicing factor which are more important,
like SC35 or SRFS1.
Right.
Yeah.
I think I understand your question.
There's a well-known splicing factor called U2AF1-
Yeah
... which has that mutation.
Right.
S34F. And we're very interested in that question.
We're doing some collaborative work with Omar Abdel now at Memorial Sloan
Kettering, trying to ask that question.
Maybe that splicing mutation also causes a
exon skipping event. It does cause exon skipping events, but we're
interested in exon skipping events in DNA repair genes.
Okay? Because then we would have an opportunity to
treat those tumors. So it has been shown that AML,
myeloid leukemias, and myelodysplastic syndrome actually has
some sensitivity to ATR inhibitors and some targeted therapy.
One of the reasons might be because those tumors might also have a defect
in MMEJ DNA repair. So thank you for that
question. Yeah.
Thank you. Thanks.
Yeah. Yeah, please.
So could you overexpress a piece of gene
containing the exon 25 to serve
as a decoy to compete away the binding of the
EWSR?
Yes. No, it's a good idea. So an ASO, could you make a-
Mm-hmm
...
peptide to come in, or, sorry, a
small oligo to come in-
Mm-hmm
... bind to that site, and compete off the splicing complex?
Yeah.
I would predict, actually, we have some data on that, that that would
cause a skipping of exon 25, and that
would knock out MMEJ.
Mm-hmm.
So that would be a possible treatment for an HR deficient tumor, another way to
treat an HR deficient tumor. So thank you for that question.
Thank you.
All right, so in the interest of time.I want to keep on time.
No question online.
Oh, there's a question online?
No.
Oh, I got to read it?
No. No question online.
No questions online. Okay. So,
the next speaker is Sharon Kantor from the University of Massachusetts.
Please join us.
Thank you.
Yeah. Great.
Well, Alan, thank you so much for the opportunity to be here.
It's my first meeting, and it's quite an
amazing, very large meeting that I'm just beginning to
understand. And so I'm going to share
today some new work from my lab. But first, just a little bit of
background,
and this is our disclosure. And so when we think about genotoxic
chemotherapy, we typically think of the induction of a DNA
double-stranded break,
and there's good support for this.
In particular, genotoxic chemotherapy is very
sensitizing to cancer cells that lack the hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer genes, BRCA1 and BRCA2.
And as we heard from Alan, these have well-established functions in
repairing DNA double-strand breaks through homologous recombination,
working with the RAD51 recombination protein.
And then we also now know that these proteins protect replication
forks from
degrading into double-strand breaks.
So through functions in preventing double-strand breaks and
actually repairing them, this is how we think about the
BRCA-ness.
These cancer cells, they can't withstand genotoxic chemotherapy,
so the table falls over, whereas a wild-type healthy cell
can prevent and repair double-strand breaks.
Now moving into synthetic lethality, this is also how we've thought about synthetic
lethality. Again, if you have BRCA1 and
PARP,
the cell will survive. But in the absence of BRCA1, such as in
a tumor,
you have these defects that I mentioned, and now you're highly dependent on
PARP for survival. And that's then why we can now take advantage of
these PARP inhibitors and selectively kill the BRCA cancer
cells.
Now, where this gets more confusing is that when we think about synthetic
lethality, we think of parallel functions, meaning common
functions, but coming from parallel pathways.
So when you use a PARP inhibitor, what we know is you're going to get
single-stranded DNA breaks and some PARP trapping.
And so it's a little unclear how that adds up to synthetic lethality.
So what we've done is rearranged the model a bit and put BRCA down
here below the DNA replication fork, dealing
with the PARP trapping or the different kinds of lesions that
ultimately are going to collapse a replication fork into a double-strand
break.
And this is how we've actually thought about lots of drugs.
So PARP's really not special in this case.
We put the BRCA pathway down below collapsed forks with many
different genotoxic agents.
And when it comes to BRCA1, it is known to actually promote homologous
recombination indirectly by opposing this
anti-resection factor, 53BP1. So in the
absence of BRCA1, the cell killing goes through
53BP1.
And so if you now get rid of 53BP1, you restore
resistance, or you restore homologous recombination.
But actually, you get very strong PARP inhibitor resistance, but not resistance
to all of the drugs that are supposed to work through this model, like
Cisplatin. You do not get resistance to that.
So a little bit confusing how this works.
Furthermore, when people started to look at DNA replication doing these DNA fiber
type assays, what they saw is that when they treated cells with a drug such as a
PARP inhibitor, replication didn't pause or collapse or
even pause. In fact, things went faster.
And so now it's really confusing. How do we get this double-strand break that we're
supposed to have when the forks collapse?
And so what was postulated is that if you go too fast, you break the speed
limit, and this gives you the double-strand break.
So in the end,
it's a bit complicated, the double-strand break model.
Lots of concessions had to be made.
And then when we see in the clinic that PARP inhibitors are sometimes working, even
when there isn't an HRD, and sometimes they're not working.
So it's been a little bit of a challenge.
So what actually could explain BRCA-ness?
So this is where we in the field have been looking at another function for the
BRCA proteins, and that is in suppressing DNA
replication gaps.
And so the reason we got so excited about this particular function is that when we
looked at our cancer cell line models that we had that were well-characterized, we
could see that the HR and the fork protection functions, they didn't
line up with therapy response. Whereas when you saw
the gaps, when they were present,
there was sensitivity. When the gaps were gone, there was resistance.
And so that
gave us some sense that this was important, at least for a biomarker, if
anything. But we also looked at RAD51 foci more
recently across these models, and that also didn't line up, and
that's something, of course, that's being used clinically.
And so an important thing to go back to then, of course, is this
BRCA1-deficient cell system. Again, when you
remove 53BP1, you restore homologous recombination.
But what we had found is it also suppresses gaps.
So then you don't really know what's driving the resistance in this case.
And what Jos Jonkers' group went on to do is to do a screen and look how you can
resensitize these double knockout cells to a PARP inhibitor.
And what he found is that ligase III loss did that.
And in his study, he found that gaps came back, but homologous
recombination remained intact. So again, suggesting that
gaps were quite important here.And so then moving on
to thinking, we're being fairly encouraged by this data.
We went on to think about how we could expand this model and suggest that
it was what's driving the DDR reactions and synthetic
lethalities that we had been working with.
And indeed, Alan D'Andrea has been working in this area as well and showing
PARP inhibitors, USP1 inhibitors, are also driving a gap
phenotype.
And so then coming together, if gaps align with response and drugs
exploit these gaps, now why are we still focused on double-strand breaks
and HRD?
Well, we'd realized these genes are called HR genes, so it's going to be
hard to take that apart. And we have really well-established
double-strand break and HRD assays.
The molecular basis of gaps is not clear.
And the gap detection assays are really time-consuming.
They're not clinically actionable.
If people have done DNA fiber assays, they're probably wishing they
hadn't.
So what I want to talk about today
are two stories. One is where Hitha,
an outstanding, talented postdoc, has now tried to define the molecular
basis of these gaps.
And then Jenna Whelan, who's here, has been developing a tool to
detect gaps, and she has a poster about that on Wednesday as well.
And so we had proposed
several years ago now that BRCA is working in parallel with PARP
to suppress replication gaps. And this came following Keith
Caldecott's work proposing that PARP is also
functioning in replication in unperturbed cells in the
lagging strand processing.
Now, this model
was supported in some ways, but we really didn't know why
BRCA1
was required to suppress 53BP1 to prevent these gaps.
And so we had to figure out how does 53BP1 fit into this space, and it is best
known for its role in double-strand break repair, but not really at the
replication fork. Now, a few years ago,
Steven Wagner's group showed that actually 53BP1 is an RNA-binding protein
that binds the lagging strand flap.
So that was a really important finding.
And so we started to think, well, is this how 53BP1 relates to
BRCA1 with respect to replication gaps?
And so in this work, they had shown that FEN1 inhibitors could be
used to show that 53BP1 was on the flap.
So using the assays like they did, these sort of PLA
or SURF assays, now we're looking at whether 53BP1
is on nascent DNA, which is labeled with Edu.
And using a FEN1 inhibitor, we could also see that we got more
53BP1 with nascent DNA
following a FEN1 inhibitor.
So then looking at a BRCA1 knockout cell from Dan
Durocher's group,
we could also see that 53BP1 was accumulating on this nascent
DNA in the absence of BRCA1, and that signal was fully
dependent on 53BP1.
Likewise, cells where BRCA1 had been complemented back dropped the
signal in a cancer cell line.
And so we didn't have any way to understand how BRCA1 might
actually process the flap, so we thought maybe it works through FEN1.
And so here now we have to ask the question: Does BRCA1 do
anything to FEN1?
And here we developed the same kind of assay where now we're going to do that
proximity assay with FEN1 and nascent DNA.
But in addition to the pulse, we're also going to add a chase here to see
when FEN1 is at the fork, when does it accumulate the most,
and when does it actually complete its association with nascent DNA.
And so what we found here in these sort of wild-type cells,
that FEN1 was here at the fork, but it accumulated just behind the
fork,
and then it rapidly dropped off, pretty much gone by 20 minutes.
And so what about BRCA1 loss? What does that do to FEN1?
So here it was quite interesting. We could see that FEN1 seemed to sort of get
stuck at the active fork, drop dramatically, and then come
back up like it was trying again behind the fork.
Saw this shift to the active fork in other BRCA mutant cell
lines.
So this is what this might look like.
In the absence of BRCA1, they're sort of
getting stuck up here, dropping, and then coming back later to try to process
the flap.
Okay, so these are synthetic lethal partners.
Does PARP also play a role in positioning FEN1?
So now we're going to do the same experiment.
So now we're going to look in the presence and the absence of PARP1.
And what we can see here is that in the absence of PARP1, we also see this
shift to the active fork, a dropping, and then a
re-accumulation further behind the fork.
And this generally mimicked what we saw with BRCA loss.
So we would argue that BRCA1 or PARP loss
give a similar kind of
phenotype here.
Okay. So now what happens if we get rid of both?
Is this relevant to the synthetic lethality?
So now we take a BRCA1-deficient cell, and we use a PARP
inhibitor, and we see something quite dramatic, and that is that there isn't really
any FEN1 making it to behind the fork.
Seems like everything is stacked up here at the fork.
And so what does that look like?
So this is what we would sort of draw this to look like.
Okay, so if this is relevant to synthetic lethality, then
53BP1 should affect this outcome.
And so what I showed you before in BRCA1-deficient cells, 53BP1 is
accumulating
at the flap. And so we could imagine then if we got rid of
53BP1 in these cells, they might start to look like a wild-type
cell, and that would explain why they're more resistant to a PARP inhibitor and
a FEN1 inhibitor and so forth.But this is where we
were very wrong. So looking at the double knockout cells,
FEN1 seemed to go away.
And so that was quite dramatic.
And we also looked in the 50BP1 single knockout cells, and
FEN1 was also dropping.
And so what Keith Caldecott has described is that the canonical
pathway, if it's not doing its job properly, PARP can
actually come to the rescue and sort of do a backup.
So we wondered if that was what was going on here.
And so now we want to look at PARP.
And so we can see that PARP was at the active fork in a wild-type cell.
If you lose BRCA1, you actually get more PARP1 at the active fork, and it seems
to persist behind the fork. If you now lose
50BP1, indeed, PARP does go up quite
dramatically at the active fork.
But the question really then became, well, is this PARP active?
Okay, so now we're going to do an antibody to the PAR activity.
And what we see is that there's more PAR activity in the BRCA1 knockout cells,
but this drops very much so when you get rid of 50BP1.
Likewise, in a 50BP1 knockout cell, we see low PAR
activity at the replication fork.
Okay, so that allows us then to put 50BP1 actually in a PARP pathway
being required for PARP activity and FEN1 positioning.
Now, if I fold this around and then put 50BP1 back on the flap, it would
look something like this. We have two pathways that are positioning
FEN1 at the replication fork, directed by 50BP1 through the
PARP, and then a separate one that BRCA1 is directing.
So how does that then play out? Well, what we think is that here you
have rapid and efficient lagging strand maturation with
these two pathways working together in a
coordinated manner. Now, if you lose BRCA1,
what you start to see is PARP working overtime because you're
not completing the task here. You have to come in later and kind of do
repeated attempts at this processing.
So it's a delayed and inefficient maturation.
And this is what we believe is causing high sensitivity then to
PARP inhibitors, because now you have lots of PARP activity to target.
So now when you lose 50BP1, you
don't have the BRCA1 positioning pathway, and you don't have the PARP
positioning pathway. So what happens?
FEN1 is disengaged,
and PARP is inactive. So this would explain why
you're not sensitive to a PARP inhibitor.
PARP's not active, and you're not sensitive to a FEN1 inhibitor because
FEN1 is not even at the replisome.
So this would argue it's about target loss, not restoration of DNA
repair.
So what can we do with this for biomarker identity?
So here in these cells, there's a lot going on.
So is there anything here we can use as a biomarker of
sensitivity to different drugs?
And so we thought, well, maturation is problematic here.
And so maturation actually can be looked at, as Beng Shen has
shown, by doing a nick translation assay.
So what he had shown is in a FEN1 knockout cell, you get these nicks or
gaps behind the fork, and you can do a nick translation assay, where you're
actually including-- now you're adding some BrdU, and you can come in with an
antibody to see that. And sure enough, we can also see with a FEN1
inhibitor, this signal goes up.
So now if you put this FEN1 inhibitor on a BRCA1 deficient cell, the
signal goes up quite a bit more,
okay? Suggesting, again, FEN1 is working very hard in these cells, and
it's very important to the maturation of the lagging strand.
Now, if you put the same FEN1 inhibitor on the double knockout cells where 50BP1
is not there, we don't see any effect.
So FEN1 inhibitor in the endogenous, no treatment
without 50B1 binding. 50BP1,
BRCA1, there's very little signal to start with, and then the inhibitor doesn't do
anything.
So this made us think, well, maybe we can just look at
the maturation as a biomarker of
this kind of sensitivity.
So can we use this nick translation or gaps or
failed maturation for a biomarker of response without
even adding any DNA damage?
So here you can see in Dan Derocher's BRCA1 knockout cells, we
can see a signal by nick translation in the absence of any DNA damage, and
that's quantified here. We can see this across
the BRCA1 vector-complemented breast cancer
cells as well. That's reversed by BRCA1 complementation.
Now, if we go to BRCA2 mutant cell lines, we see a similar thing where without
BRCA2, there is a higher inherent
signal.
Now, what about in derived resistant lines?
Well, here too, you can see that
MDC-1 loss, which confers resistance to PARP inhibitors, the signal
drops. A derived resistant cell line
in ovarian breast. This is an ovarian cancer
reversion cell line where, again, the signal goes down.
And also a model we had discovered several years ago.
Again, across the board, resistance leads to lower gap scores.
And so we can put that in a table here where you can see across these various
models, our gap signal is lower when cells are resistant and higher
when they're sensitive. And this extends beyond BRCA
proficiency that we can see as well.
So PARP inhibitor sensitivity, for example, in this particular mutant
here, also correlates with more
gaps.Okay. So again, will GAP succeed in
the clinic? We need to do robust preclinical
validation. We want to run a retrospective study and actually
compare the GAP signature to HRD and see how we
do, and then start to explore it as a companion diagnostic.
We've launched a company based on this, and again, Jenna has a poster on
Wednesday that she would probably really appreciate you guys coming
over.
And so then just to summarize, we now would like to propose
that it's about
gap repair protection, good
lagging strand maturation. If we want drugs to work, we want to maximize
gaps, and we want to make sure we can prevent gap suppression
pathways,
gap repair proteins, and gaps themselves will be biomarkers
of response.
Thank my team, our collaborators, our funding
sources,
and also just want to give a shout-out to a meeting that'll be in about a year from
now. I hope that you guys will come.
And finally, just leave this up as a summary, and I'm happy to take
any questions. Thank you.
Thank you. Great talk.
Thank you.
Given the
highly pleiotropic role of BRCA1 and BRCA2 and these
different functions, do you think we should move beyond this crude instrument
of BRCAness, of HRD, and focus on finding what makes these
two proteins distinct, and how do they function differently to each other?
So if I understand your question, in terms of focusing on this
biology, whether how BRCA2 and BRCA1-
Yeah
... relate to each other in here?
So whether BRCA1 might have roles
in DNA gaps, but also in homologous
recombination and replication stress, where BRCA2 might have
mostly a function in homologous recombination and DNA gaps.
And maybe that's why also we see different signatures in these two
different backgrounds.
Okay. Yeah, no, I think it's a fair point because certainly these other functions
in homologous recombination are going to affect the mutation signatures and so
forth.
But what we would argue is that BRCA1 and BRCA2
share
a maturation phenotype that is inherent, I think, to why
the drugs are sensitizing.
Thank you.
Hi, Sharon. Very nice. I was wondering, have you looked at the other alternate
Okazaki fragment processing proteins, DNA2, PIF in the double knockouts, and
would you expect to see those go up?
Yeah, great question. So in the double knockout cells, there
is another backup pathway taking over, and actually DNA2 is not
part of it because, as was already shown, we could
confirm that 50BP1 is required for DNA2 localization to the flap as
well.
Have you looked at the PIF helicase?
I have not looked at PIF, but what we see is XRCC1, ligase 3
are critical-
Yeah
... in this backup pathway.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Hi, Sharon. A really great talk.
Thank you.
I was just wondering if you looked at all at FEN1's interaction with
PCNA, its PIT box. Does that have any role
in your model?
Yeah, no, it's a really important thing.
There's so many things of structure function for us to take apart
that we haven't even begun, that we don't have the bandwidth.
But certainly PCNA bringing FEN1 to the active fork, and then
what we think is happening, it's got to get back behind the fork to do the flap.
And so it's got to actually come off of PCNA, and that's where we think
PARP and BRCA1 are helping to move it.
Very cool. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.
Let me just make a point.
Yeah.
Good stage. So just got two minutes left.
Just to make the point, in preparing for this session, went back and read the early
papers, right? It was 20 years ago that
Alan Ashworth and Thomas Helleday demonstrated in back-to-back Nature
papers that PARP inhibitors are synthetic lethal with BRCA-deficient
cells. And over the last 20 years, we've figured out several different mechanisms
of PARP, and you've just shown us a new one.
We know that PARP traps, and now we know that PARP recruits FEN1,
and I think
as a research tool, PARP inhibitors have been incredibly valuable
to the DNA repair community. But now, of course,
PARP inhibitors are approved, FDA approved for
a number of breast, ovarian, prostate, pancreatic cancers.
And so I think that it's been-- But we still need more
DDR inhibitors, and I think that now, I think Sharon's talk really says that a
FEN1 inhibitor might have a real role here in increasing these gaps
on the lagging strand. So any thoughts about that, or?
Sure. Yeah. So what our data are
suggesting is that PARP and FEN1 are in the same pathway,
right? So the PARP inhibitor and the FEN1 inhibitor,
therefore, should not synergize, right?
And so just understanding that the way we think that PARP
are sensitizing is by failing to get FEN1
placed properly for its flap processing.
Great.
So that's how we're thinking about it.
Yeah. Thank you.
All right. So, the last speaker then, happy to introduce
Pamela Munster from UC San Francisco, and greatly look
forward to your talk.
Thank you, and thank you for the organizer for
inviting me, and it's a pleasure to really follow
on these two exceptional talks, and it also suggests a
little bit of how far we have to go. As you said, Alan Ashworth
showed 20 years ago that PARP inhibitors could be clinically valuable.
I want to really preface this. This is synthetic
lethality beyond BRCA from the perspective of a
treating physician, as I am a... translational scientist,
everything I do is focused on what are we going to do in patients.
Here are my disclosures. So when you approach a
patient with a HRR gene mutation or HRD,
or generally therapeutically, you have to ask yourself a
couple of essential questions. Well, how common are HRR
mutation, meaning the gene is mutated, beyond BRCA1 and BRCA2,
and are they key drivers?
The non-BRCA HRR then versus the gene is intact,
but the functional protein cascade is
deficient. And then is there relevant tissue context?
If you have an ATM mutation in breast cancers, it's the
same as in pancreatic cancer. And then we
know that we have very defined tumors that are more
likely linked to an HRR germline mutation.
Are they more vulnerable to our current drugs, or
is HRD the same?
And then looking at them as therapeutic targets opens very similar
questions. And just please forgive me, I'm not even going in the variants of
unknown significance, which is a major topic for
clinicians. And then how can we target HRD beyond the PARP
inhibitors? So
as both Sharon and Alan have beautifully shown, it's like
these are interfering with
double strength and single strength DNA breaks, and then it's
repair. But when we're looking at the more classic
mutations that we see in the clinic, these are PALB2, the partner and localizer of
BRCA2, bridges BRCA1 and 2, ATM,
ataxia-telangiectasia mutant, is an atypical kinase sensing
double strand breaks, the check point
kinase 2, and it is really an important
target because I really want to point out that this is not
sensitive to most PARP inhibitor
modulation. Then RAD51C, RAD51D, and many
others, and then BRP1, and there are many others.
Looking at clinically, what are the important
definitions and categorizations?
The classic ones, of course, BRCA1 and BRCA2.
Then PALB2 is by many accepted as
kind of BRCA3, but it's not officially called BRCA3, but
very similar to BRCA1 and BRCA2. But then
ATM, CHEK, RAD51, and CDK12
are fairly prominent target in
the clinic, and then the others are probably just as
relevant target, but not as frequently expressed.
And then if we don't have a genetic mutation,
but we have a functional mutation, we can look at this
by either high loss of heterozygosity, LOH, telomeric
allele imbalance, large-scale state transitions.
Multiple assays now look at various mutational signature,
epigenetic silencing, methylation of BRCA1 promoters
is pretty common.
Or we look at this restoring of sensitivity of
carboplatin or a PARP inhibitor.
So
frequent germline HRD mutations for three
HRR-linked mutation, typically, we're talking metastatic
prostate cancer, breast cancer, and pancreatic cancer.
And what you see here is BRCA2 in all three is
actually very prominent. This actually has now a BRCA2
mutation in pancreatic cancer as well as ATM mutation in
pancreatic cancer has led to formalized screening of
germline carriers for ATM and BRCA2.
So if you have such a mutation, we start screening for pancreatic cancer.
We have always screened for breast cancer and prostate cancer for those with
germline mutations. But you see ATM, CHEK2,
BRCA1 is sort of overarching for
all three of these typically HRR link tumors.
However, if you look at now two tumor types that
are very common but not classically associated with
HRD mutation or HRR genes, it's like you look at
colon cancer, just 7.6% of colon cancer have a germline
mutation.
I think there's a very high attention on the Lynch gene for colon
cancer, of course, because of its therapeutic implications.
But if you look carefully, BRCA1, BRCA2, ATM, and
PALB2 is present in just
around 3% or 4% of colon cancer. That's not trivial given
how successful these are as therapeutic targets.
Similarly, in lung cancer, 15% of lung cancer have a germline
mutation. Again, BRCA2, BRCA1,
ATM, PALB2, and CHEK are quite
common. So looking beyond the
classic
BRCA gene, if you want.
So looking at this more globally, and I just told you about 15% of lung
cancer have a germline mutation. This is fitting right
in here. So here's lung cancer. So
in a different way, looking at 52,000 tumor cells
evaluated for germline mutation, you see there's many tumors are
actually very rich in germline mutations.
So I think
really important, anyone with a metastatic prostate cancer,
breast cancer, or pancreatic cancer is now getting screened for germline
mutation, but maybe we need to do more.
Maybe we need to globally screen everyone for germline mutations.
Not only because it has therapeutic implications, but it has very clear
implications for family members.
In one of the major representatives are
ATM, ATRX,
BRCA1, BRCA2, BRP1,
across a large group of tumors, even someone like
biliary cancer, bladder cancer, liver cancer, and
gastric. So this is much more common than we originally
thought.So PARP inhibitors are
approved, but the approval, despite the fact that they have
shown benefits in many diseases, are really only approved in
limited indication. That is, in ovarian cancer maintenance, PARP
inhibitors are pretty much approved to BRCA1, BRCA2, and anyone
with a HRD score.
And that is true for most of the PARP inhibitors,
except for talazoparib, which is not approved in ovarian
cancer. If you look at pancreatic
cancer, it's limited to BRCA1 or BRCA2 germline
mutation or somatic. Breast cancer is germline or somatic.
But if you look at prostate cancer, so BRCA1 or BRCA2 is universal
approval for PARP inhibitor, for olaparib,
niraparib,
rucaparib, and talazoparib. But if you look carefully, once you go
beyond the BRCA1, BRCA2, ATM, and CDK12,
you actually have to look very carefully which PARP inhibitor you're allowed to use
in the clinic because the sub-mutations are actually
different.
Olaparib has different approvals for Bard1,
Brip1, Chek1, and Chek2 versus the
talazoparib.
When we're looking at synthetic lethality beyond BRCA, then now we start looking
not just PARP inhibitor, but combination therapy, and I want to walk you
through some of the combination therapies that we have looked at.
And then in the last step, I'd like to focus a little bit
on other HRD mutation targeting agents, and I
think Alan has nicely walked you through POL
data.
So prostate cancer, metastatic prostate cancer,
patient receiving enzalutamide, which is
anti-androgen for metastatic prostate
cancer, with or without talazoparib.
If you look at overall survival for all patients, like
not selected for the mutation, there's a hazard ratio of 0.8,
so 20% of patient benefit, statistically significant.
And if you look here, this is 60 months, this is five years.
Men live a long time with metastatic prostate cancer and the
curves continue to separate. So a PARP inhibitor
appears to benefit men with prostate cancer.
If we look at it more carefully, if you look at the HRD
mutation versus deficient
HRR gene alterations,
again, by the defined mutations as I outlined
just before,
there's a very significant difference in overall
survival with a hazard ratio now almost 0.5.
With HRR intact or unknown status, the
benefits
really are not quite as clear.
So if you look at the subsets, again, BRCA1 or BRCA2, really
profound
benefits in BRCA2 with both progression-free survival
and overall survival, and you see here is similar to what we
found in breast cancer with HER2 overexpression.
We know HER2 overexpression in breast cancer predicts for
poor outcome. Well, once we have HER2 targeting therapy, those women do
exceptionally well. I think the same is true for BRCA2 mutations.
While BRCA2 in prostate cancer conveys a worse and more
aggressive tumor, if you look at the benefits of
the PARP inhibitors, it's very significant, both for
progression-free survival and overall survival.
BRCA1 in prostate cancer is less common.
The benefits are less clear.
So let's move over to CDK12 and PALB2.
To the left here, the progression-free survival, you see the
differences. The difference is holding up in overall survival,
but the differences are less clear.
If you now look at ATM mutation in prostate
cancer, despite the fact that the PARP
inhibitors are approved for ATM mutated prostate cancer,
the benefits are probably not
great. And if you look at Chek2,
there's no benefit in terms of progression-free
survival. But if you look at the overall survival, now the curve's actually
flipped. The outcomes for someone with a
Chek2 mutation getting a PARP inhibitor may be actually
reversed. So think, really be
mindful that for men with a
ATM or Chek2 mutated prostate cancer, maybe the PARP inhibitor
alone may be not the optimal choice, despite its approval.
Memorial Sloan Kettering did a single center retrospective study in patient with
metastatic castrate-resistant prostate cancer,
receiving a PARP inhibitor and found a very similar picture.
Significant benefit for patients with BRCA1 or
BRCA2,
benefit with CDK12, but there's very few patients who
actually really have a long benefit when you have an ATM mutation.
So it's like for us, it's really crucial to find out who are the people with this
mutation who benefit, and other than the gene
mutation, what happens downstream, and I think I cannot
focus enough. We really need more research to
do just by our patients.
So looking at combination of immunotherapy.
When we looked at PARP inhibitors early on, there was
this
lots of emerging evidence suggesting if a PARP inhibitor
creates an increased mutational burden, may
convey sensitivity toAn immune checkpoint inhibitor.
How solid these somewhat simplified
theories
remains to be seen. But this was one of the first trial looking at
pembrolizumab, an immune checkpoint inhibitor, and a PARP inhibitor, niraparib, in
platinum-resistant ovarian cancer.
Platinum-resistant ovarian cancer, by definition,
is supposed to be conveying resistance to a
PARP inhibitor. And what we found in our group, we had 75% had
resistance and 24% had intolerance, meaning just how
long it has been and what the benefits were for the PARP inhibitors.
Most of these patients had BRCA wild type.
HRD positivity was seen in 35%, and about
56% had PD-L1 expression, which is probably a bit high
for an ovarian cancer. But you see we have very nice responses
in the combination,
and often just in HRD positive patients as well
in HRD negative patients. And that what you see here
is what's really striking to us,
despite the fact that these patients have progressed on platinum, many of them
had
five plus years benefit on the combination.
I think the important part is to take home from this talk,
when PARP inhibitors work with or without immunotherapy, the
duration of response can often be very prolonged.
And I think from a clinician offering
therapies that cost three plus years, the
therapy benefits is really rewarding.
So then KEYLINK-007 looked at
a PARP inhibitor with immunotherapy in multiple tumor type, looking at
tumor agnostic. They had to have an either
HRR
by mutations, by protocol defined
mutations, or HRD, but with the
impaired DNA repair with a LOH score of more than
16. And I think you're recognizing a theme,
BRCA1 or BRCA2 have more benefits than others.
In the non-BRCA mutated HRR mutated patients, you
see there's very solid benefit too, less clear
than in the BRCA1 or BRCA2. And then
similarly in the HRR wild type with HRD
mutations benefits. But so who is benefiting here?
Going back to just looking at BRCA1 and BRCA2 across multiple tumor
types, very significant benefit in GI
tumors, endocrine, neuroendocrine tumor, endometrial tumors,
non-small lung cancer, really across a tumor
agnostic
field. And you see again is the benefits are
beyond 30 months. Many patients have a benefit beyond 30 months.
And
if you see just what it means to have pancreatic cancer and
even a year response is, it is quite
rewarding for us.
So again, the mutations that fall out for benefit
here are ATM, actually, BRIP1, and PALB2.
Two patients with ATM mutation in ovarian and breast cancer,
suggesting that ATM may convey resistance to a PARP inhibitor
in prostate cancer. This may not be so in other diseases.
Now flipping the combination of
immunotherapy and a PARP inhibitor for a minute towards a
mismatch repair. So in tumors who have
mismatch repair, immunotherapy is highly
effective.
But if those who don't have a mismatch repair, can we make
them susceptible to chemotherapy?
So this trial looked at advanced endometrial cancer,
looking at the PARP inhibitor olaparib and the immune checkpoint inhibitor
durvalumab. And what you see here in blue, the
combination of durva ola
is much better than the durvalumab alone or the control
arm, which has chemotherapy. So again, suggesting that
in mismatch repair tumors, you actually may see a benefit.
However, when we looked at this a bit more carefully, look at the
sub-type analysis, the
major benefits from the combination is seen in
the durva ola, but we don't know what the durva alone does in the mismatch
repair. So if someone is exquisitely sensitive to immunotherapy,
do we improve much? We don't know yet.
But we see a difference in those with a mismatch repair
intact tumor. So the benefits here that
a PARP inhibitor may add to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Similar study with another immune checkpoint inhibitor and
dostarlimab and then niraparib very similar to this.
So then the question we took back to the lab in a very generous
support from Merck is could we predict this in the lab?
So my highly talented postdoc,
Dibapriya Chowdhury,
started knocking out
select HRR genes, and these include
BRCA1, BRCA2, PALB2, ATM, and CHEK in two breast
cancer models that are inducible.
And this was done with CRISPR-Cas9.
So what we found is looking at the wild type, the
IC50 for--
This is the 231 breast cancer model, triple negative
human isogenetic breast cancer model.
So we see we lower the IC50 for ATM and CHEK2
by somewhat, but probably not by much.
But if you look at BRCA1, very significant change in
IC50, inducing BRCAness, if you
willSimilarly, when we now looked at the
immune competent mouse model as a EMT six, she
knocked out BRCA12, ATM, PALB2, and CHEK, and you see here
really very significant reduction in the
IC50 for BRCA1 and PALB2
and
BRCA2. You see here that it does seem like the PALB2 in
therapeutic response in breast cancer does fall somewhere between BRCA1 and
BRCA2.
When we then looked at combination of immune checkpoint inhibitor and PARP
inhibitor, we actually don't see anything in the wild type as we
would expect, and we see very
profound synergistic interaction for the immune checkpoint
inhibitor and the olaparib in this immune competent
mouse. That holds true for BRCA1, BRCA2, and PALB2.
When we go to ATM,
we kind of don't see that much.
We really don't see the benefit. But again,
in this mouse model, when we actually look at the
CHEK2 mutation, they have a nice response with immune checkpoint inhibitor.
But really when we add the PARP inhibitors, the benefits are
actually lost. Again, the PARP inhibitor would actually convey
resistance to these tumors. So
in the last 20 seconds, I'm going to go a little bit through the new
ATR, ATM mutations.
You don't have to rush. We're doing good.
All right. Thank you. I'll take a couple more minutes.
So a lot of effort on what's happening on the
ATR inhibitors, re inhibitors, and ATM inhibitors.
ATM inhibitors probably haven't made it quite right out of the
gate. But
it's not surprising that you would see the ATR pathway, which
inhibits single strand breaks, has a close link to the ATM
pathway.
So what are we seeing here?
Looking at an ATR inhibitor,
when the initial studies were done, and
Timothy Yap has been a very solid
investigator in this field, it was very clear that in
all comers, the ATR inhibitors haven't really
done as much. But what emerged in the ATR inhibitor is
that if you have a mutation in ATM, there you actually now
convey benefit. BRCA1 and BRCA2 still are good
targets, but here is now where the ATR inhibitor really
convey benefits.
This was with camozertib, and then
Rahul Aggarwal, my colleague at UCSF, and
colleagues have done this study with serolazertib in
ARID1A-deficient solid tumor malignancies,
and this is a ChatGDP rendering and how
ARID1A interacts with
the ATR pathway, and
you see there's a connection that ATR does convey sensitivity.
And here again, we have
very significant durable benefits of
serolazertib in ARID1
mutated solid tumors. The phase two in
endometrial cancer and other tumors is ongoing, and we are
going to hopefully have an update for you.
Similarly, when we use the PARP inhibitor and a TOPO inhibitor for
patients with ATM mutation, we see prolonged
duration of responses with
the combination in the ATM background.
So ATM is a
mutation that is really requiring a lot more studies.
I think we have a little bit of a handle on it, probably not just the PARP
inhibitor alone. So in summary,
PARP mutations are much more common in tumors that are not typically
associated with HRR mutation. And I think I
want you to take home that
if you have a tumor that's not a typical HRR tumor, there still could be
a mutation. If you have a germline mutation, it really has
significant implication for your families.
To go through this, BRCA1 and BRCA2 are probably the most
consistent targets.
ATM, RAD51, CDKME convey sensitivity, but less
so.
New drugs are incoming, and there's a lot of
opportunity for research. With this, thank you very much, and
gratitude to all the patients and their loved ones who contribute to advances
by participating.
Is
this working? Yeah, I have a quick question. The BRIP1 is interesting.
So that's mutated in the prostate cancer.
Is that showing efficacy with a PARP inhibitor? I missed what you had said.
The data is less clear because it's quite uncommon.
So we have-
Yeah
... a couple of patients.
Okay.
In breast cancer, yeah.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And I think particularly, I think if you go back in
Keylink 007, there's definitely benefits, and
the benefits are BRIP1 in multiple tumor types.
Thank you.
Sharon's interested
in this because she cloned BRIP1 when she was a postdoc with David Livingston some
years ago, so there's an extra interest on her part, and that was a clear
answer. Similarly,
the
initial findings were misleading about PARP inhibitor for
ATM-deficient prostate cancer, but you are finding some
responses now. And in the DNA repair research
field, it's also confusing becauseATM is not
really an HR gene per se,
but clearly you are seeing some
durable responses with PARP inhibitor in
ATM-deficient tumors.
Any thoughts as to what biomarkers might help
distinguish the responders from the non-responders?
I think the story is a little bit
more complicated. I think in BRCA1 and BRCA2 germline
mutations, you typically have HRD.
There's a subsequent loss of BRCA1 and BRCA2 signaling is pretty clear.
I don't think that's quite as clear with ATM.
I think we have looked particularly in
Aggarwal's trial, we looked at
ATM expression on the protein level, and it's
not quite clear on the tumors that had loss of ATM expression on
ATM HRD were clearly more
sensitive to tumors. And I think for ATM, maybe just having the
mutation analysis on the gene level may not be sufficient.
I think you may have to need biallelic loss.
Mm-hmm. And how about the actual mutational signature
itself? Have mutational signatures been helpful in
distinguishing a PARP inhibitor
sensitive
ATM mutant tumor versus not? Or has that been
a useful tool for-
Yeah, I think as we are learning, I think we have
just been so much better in
BRCA1 or BRCA2 to calling out VUSs
or non-pathogenic mutations. I don't think we
have done as well for ATM, and particularly not for CHEK2.
CHEK2 has so many sort of
non-relevant therapeutic targets.
I think the problem is that we still bin them in one big group as
CHEK2 is probably not fair. I think
similarly, when we look at EGFR mutation, we don't just have all EGFR mutation,
we have very specific EGFR mutations.
I don't think we are there yet with CHEK2 or even ATM.
Right. One question.
Hi. Nice talk. Thanks. Mark Vincent from London, Ontario.
Can you tell us about radiation sensitivity
and HRD? Are they more sensitive and maybe
mismatch repair as well?
So my lab has been looking at
augmenting
PARP inhibitors for radiation therapy because
in many people, the PARP inhibitors are still fairly
toxic.
And if we could augment that with radiation therapy, we could
probably bring this in the earlier setting.
I think prostate cancer, bringing a PARP inhibitor with radiation
therapy, either to shrink the tumor or make the radiation field
smaller or enhance the PCR rate will
probably be really helpful.
And I think-
Is there any data, though? We've been radiating prostate cancer for about
100 years. Surely, in retrospect, we know that some of them had
BRCA2, and do we know that there's a higher incidence of either toxicity
or benefit?
I don't think the data is clearly established.
What was very clear when they even did the TALAPRO trial, where they look
at metastatic prostate cancer, and there's a
very large group of people have not had HRR assessment.
Yeah.
And I think there was a big discussion on the ODAC on
several of these trials, like why can't we do germline testing?
Because as you know, with the early prostate cancer, often the biopsies
are not sent for tissue testing. The germline
testing is not universally done.
My colleague, Allison Kurian, has presented data in JAMA
two years ago suggesting that even in prostate cancers, less than 10% of
men who actually get tested. So I think the problem is we don't have a
consistent
HRR testing in these men. So I think it's a really good question,
and we should have the data, and we still don't. But thank you for that.
Thank you.
Good.
All right.
Thank you very much